d'accord allons au travail je cours quand
tu flippes non oui tu es
quelqu'un vient de me guider à travers ce que nous sommes
censés faire
tu as
besoin de cheveux frais parce que tu es sur le point d'en
avoir beaucoup d'accord on y va
[Musique]
juste au moment où tu ne pensais pas qu'il pouvait s'améliorer
elle et ce n'est pas pour
toi ce n'est pas ta mission hé hé
quoi de neuf mec parle moi allez je ne peux pas le
faire [ __ ] tu ne peux pas venir mec tu jettes
ce truc à l'envers et
sors ton cul ici maintenant  écoutez je ne peux pas le faire d'accord
écoutez ce que je dis maintenant ce n'est pas le
moment de
rester là-haut avec le pilote nous
allons faire le tour et nous assurer que nous
tenons à mort pour ma bière tu
cours à l'heure  la goulotte est guidée par
GPS vous n'avez rien à faire de bien
je suis déjà dessus
hé mec écoute je suis désolé de vous laisser
tomber d'accord je vais  vas-y et reste ici
et je vais mon frère je suis désolé de t'avoir laissé
tomber en classe tu es prêt
pas fou bien que
cette fois il ne s'agit pas seulement d'être rapide
ouais
toi